Hong Kong us are used to queuing for
restaurants conventions but not for an
election especially not on a Sunday
morning and even before the polling
stations open moments after the queue
started form came a familiar face
pro-democracy leader Joshua Wong he
himself was part from running this free
council election is the election in more
community-based focus on more district
or Constitution issue instead of overall
Hong Kong political system reform but I
still urge people both in election to
show our discontent to Beijing many
voters see these local elections as a
referendum on whether the public still
supports the protests Hong Kong has been
rocked by almost 6 months of unrest some
of it violent but calm returned in a
run-up to the election protesters feared
the government might call off the vote
we are facing an extremely challenging a
situation in organizing this year's
elections but I'm pleased to say that
with the concerted efforts of all
parties including of course over 30,000
civil servants in many departments
working today we should have a
relatively peaceful and calm environment
to conduct these elections successfully
for now peace has temporarily returned
to the city but this could change
depending on the results and for more
I'm joined now by our correspondent on
the ground at Charlotte Chelsea until
Charlotte tell us what's happening where
you are
Nicke district council elections like
this one rarely attracts a huge amount
of fanfare here in Hong Kong or
internationally of course as well but
this year has been very different record
numbers of people have registered to
take part in the vote we've been
standing at this polling station most of
the day today they've know that the
majority of the day they've been huge
crowds lining up to cast their ballots
in these district council elections
people we've spoken to tell us that they
think it's their duty as Hong Kong
citizens to to have their say to to cast
their ballots here now all eyes of
course are on this vote because it's
being considered a litmus test a
referendum if you like on the
authorities here and the pro-democracy
movement which is now in its six months
six months people here say that they
want to to send a message either for or
against those protests through the
ballot box here now today via these
district council elections so tell us a
little bit more what's at stake here if
you would at once symbolically and in
strict political institutional terms
well this is the first time since the
unrest here began in June that people
have had the opportunity to go to the
ballot box to vote in an election and to
send a message to authorities or to the
pro-democracy movement whether they are
for or against the unrest that has has
taken over Hong Kong in recent months it
will of course have a very symbolic
meaning of this election that's taking
place here today the pro-establishment
parties have long dominated the district
council elections they are going to be
on the defensive they want to make sure
that they hang on to their support any
sign that it's slipping away to
pro-democracy candidates will be taken
as a slight against the authorities here
pretty moxy candidates meanwhile are
really battling to take their fight to
the ballot box to prove to legitimize
what they've been taking to the streets
for for so many months now now on a more
practical level this will also impact
Hong Kong's future going forward and the
that it's government governed so six
district councillors will be able to
join the Legislative Council Hong Kong's
Parliament if you like going forward as
well number dozens of these district
councillors will then join the committee
which will appoint the chief executive
next time around so pro-democracy
candidates really see this as while the
district councillors don't have a huge
amount of power it is a step for them if
they do make gains in the right
direction you've been there for weeks
and months now covering the weekend
demonstrations occasionally marred by
violence is there any fear of that
reoccurring today yeah the weeks leading
up to this election were some of the
most violent that we have seen in with
it in this whole of five over five
months a pro-democracy movement now the
days ahead of it it was quite quiet
there was an uneasy calm here in Hong
Kong we were seeing and hearing from
pro-democracy activists that they wanted
to to keep the peace here they didn't
want to give the authorities a reason to
cancel or suspend these elections so
they have been Karma we've seen on the
social media groups that they've been
urging pro-democracy activists not to
come to these polls wearing wearing back
or chanting pro-democracy slogans
anything that could stop them casting
their ballots so today has remained very
peaceful so far there are riot police
who are patrolling all the polling
stations to ensure that that stays the
case throughout the evening just though
is a testament to the violence that has
gripped Hong Kong for so many months now
this is in fact the constituency of a
local a candidate a local politician
whose ear was bitten off during an
attack by an assailant not so long ago
so this boat has been gripped by
violence in the lead-up to a number of
district councillors however faced
similar attacks today though still
peaceful thanks for that DW Charlotte
Joslyn till reporting from Hong Kong
you